now an NHS worker has been reunited with
her children after they were sent to
live with relative during lockdown well
the mother with the surprise appearance
heiress Suzy works at the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital in King's Lynn she'd
been working on a coded nineteen ward
her daughter's nine year old Ellis
enrolled Ettie I've been staying with
their arm to keep them safe this is the
first time they'd seen their mother in
some nine weeks what's guys Rob Dorset
is with the family right now Rob yeah
calling that video has gone viral on
social media perhaps for a couple of
reasons maybe one because a lot of
people have been feeling isolated in
these lockdown times and can relate to
it a little bit but I think also perhaps
it emphasizes just how those on the
front line in the fight against Cove in
nineteen the NHS workers the care home
workers have probably sacrificed more
and maybe a lot of us and with losing
the girls now as you say here they are
are thanks for talking to this everybody
but let's talk to Susie first Susie
trying explain exactly what your role is
at the Curie Hospital at King's Lynn and
why that meant you had to make this
really tough decision to send the girls
away I'm an operating department
practitioner which means I normally help
the any participant patients to sleep
for their operation so I have airway
skills which meant that my skills could
be used in ITU and also in their covert
alien recess and basically the decision
to send the girls away was to keep them
safe because I didn't know what I was
going to be bringing home but it also
meant that I could devote more hours to
work and help look after these patients
how difficult was it been it's been
really difficult it's been emotionally
and physically exhausting yeah come home
to this house empty everyday knowing
that you were doing it for the greater
good didn't make it any easier I guess
no it didn't I definitely had my moments
but keeping in touch with the girls
every day
FaceTime in text messages saying good
morning mummy
me and how's your day being just kept me
going I knew that they would you know be
a time when we would all be back
together soon Hattie
no aunty Charlotte was a really good fun
but how difficult was it for you to be
away from your was really hard and not
seeing mummy but and Bella always said
can we teleport to you mummy was a bit
cheeky wasn't she sneaking up on you in
the video like that what did you think
when you when you saw her behind you
what do you think about the work that
your mummys been doing Bella because
obviously you know she's been working
with some very poorly patients who've
had coronavirus and that's men you
haven't been able to see her but you
must have been quite proud of it what do
you think the adoration of your
daughters that goes without saying but
the other ation of the public I think a
lot as well if you guys on the front
line felt that from the outside yes
we've had a lot of support from the
public as well as our surrounding
community in Norfolk it's been great
it's been overwhelming and you said it
was a difficult decision to send the
girls away how difficult a decision to
say okay look I think it's safe enough
for us to come back again and then again
another difficult decision is it safe I
can't guarantee that nobody can
guarantee that but the fact that I've
been away from them for nine weeks was
mainly enough for me and I was obviously
exhausted too so it was time to get back
to it a little bit of normality if we
possibly can in this situation you're on
the frontline are you seeing any
dwelling of the of the fight against
Cove in 19 that the stats would seem to
suggest that we're winning this slowly
but you still have fears of a second
peak what are you seeing on the
frontline there the numbers are reducing
which is brilliant and I just hope that
that continues to
then measures people stick Barnum yes
definitely still stick to the rules we
will get there eventually well it's
lovely to see you all back together Suze
you and the girls thanks very much
indeed for talking to us that Suzie
Hetty and Bella reunited again after
nine weeks and as you can hear there
they don't wanna be separated again well
thanks very much